I buy about 50 books a year I skim most  of them and I study a select few here  are the only books that I have studied  and I reread every so often in no order  number one is influenced by Robert  chaldini the second book is persuasion  also by Robert chaldini third is 50  scientific ways of getting to yes which  is also chaaldini's Forest effort  Secrets by Russell Brunson one to many  by Jason fladley number six is ready  fire aim number seven is how to make  friends and influence people eight is  wooden on leadership number nine was  bezos's letters to shareholders 10 100  million offers and I have to say that I  studied it more because I've read that  book more than any other book because I  wrote it sales acceleration formula by  Mark Roberts predictable Revenue by  Aaron Ross and the final one which I  have which is number 13 is the motive by  Patrick lincione those are the 13 books  that probably most influence my business  career